hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and let's start with a very
quick meta note about what's going on
with the podcast in particular I wanted
to mention that we now have transcripts
of every episode that are going to
appear on the web page with the
individual posts for the episodes will
have the entire transcript as soon as it
appears this of course cost money I'm
not doing it myself so a huge thank you
to those who are supporting the podcast
on patreon you're the ones who made that
possible so I think this is gonna be
very good both for accessibility and
also for search ability you can go in
and you can see what's the podcast is
about even before you listen to it
search for terms throughout the whole
archives that's gonna be really good
moving on to today's show I want you to
think about what is happening in your
brain at this very moment you're
listening to my words or you're reading
the words if you're reading the
transcripts one way or another there's a
signal coming in let's just say that
you're listening so you're hearing
sounds so there's a vibration going on
in your eardrums words sentences and so
forth and you can recognize these words
just like you can recognize nonverbal
sounds but there's something else going
on that like the set of words coming in
we create meaning we attach to these
words to these sounds that we're hearing
some picture of what I'm trying to say
some relationship between these sounds
and something out there in the world or
some abstract concept or something like
that so how does that happen how is it
that a bunch of sounds hitting our
eardrums get turned into meaning inside
the brain that's what we're talking
about on today's episode with Professor
David purple who is a professor at NYU
and also the director of a mock Splunk
Institute in Frankfurt Germany I love
this his max planck institute is called
the institute for empirical aesthetics i
have no idea what that means but I know
that what David does is actually study
what's going on inside your brain he
studies it not primarily with the
standard fMRI picture which is when you
put someone's brain inside someone's
head and you don't think the brain out
you put someone's head in
cite a machine and look at where the
blood is flowing to to pinpoint where
things are happening in the brain which
is very precise in terms of where things
are happening but it's slow you can't
see when things are happening
so mostly David uses em eg machines
Magneto and cephalo graph machines to
see exactly when a thought is happening
inside your brain in fact if you have my
book of the big picture you can see an
image of my brain not the conventional
wrinkly crinkly thing that you're used
from pictures of the brain but just a
very crude image of that quadrants of my
brain in which different magnetic fields
are appearing as charged particles race
around from neuron to neuron perfect
evidence that I really do have a brain
inside my head so it turns out that this
question we're asking about how sounds
get turned into language and meaning
people have thought about this for a
long time there's a standard model if
you like but that standard model
appeared in the 1800s and has not been
updated as much as you would like since
then so with his collaborator Greg
Hickok david purple has suggested a
updated model something called the dual
stream model which isolates not just one
part of the brain but different parts of
the brain that are responsible for
different aspects of language processing
we'll talk about that exactly how it
works and also just because David is an
opinionated guy will talk about all
sorts of other issues in neuroscience
including the role of big data how we're
coming along and understanding memory
and so forth so let's go
[Music]
David purple welcome to the mindscape
podcast hi there nice to be here yeah
this is completely by accident that
we've met each other or you know we've
known each other for a while you were
famous participant at the moving
naturalism forward meeting back in 2012
but now we happened to be in the area
where you lived so of course I'm gonna
podcast you and that's great what let's
start by laying the groundwork I'm
trying to think of a way for the
audience to describe what you do for a
living you're like a professor in half
of the departments of the various
universities that you're a member of is
it okay to say thought and language well
it's fair enough
I mean the a one-liner that I try to
remind myself of is a study how you go
from vibrations in the ear to
abstraction z' in the head so as we're
having this conversation the only signal
you're actually getting is your eardrum
vibrating because i'm sending sound your
way and amazingly that turns into
abstract ideas words ideas in your head
so the fact that that works at all is
already amazing and weird and all the
sub process sub processes are things
that i study in my labs
yeah i mean it's a great way of putting
it because really the position of the
eardrum it only vibrates in one
dimension right it's only in and out so
we get one number time stream into our
brain and from that we create everything
we think about it's the fact that it
works at all is astonishing and the fact
that it works at the speed at which
we're doing it is even more astonishing
you have a bunch of you have tens of
thousands of words stored in your head
and we're sitting in this know my lovely
backyard in Connecticut and it's a
little bit noisy we might see a bear
walk by and it's and yet you can extract
complicated information in you know
segments of tens of milliseconds how
does that work at all and so those are
the kinds of problems I worry about and
that includes obviously listening to
music listening to sounds that are not
speech but the major emphasis in my lab
is on speech perception and language
comprehension just a note for podcast
listeners if a bear does walk by I will
let you know but we are inside we're
relatively safe right
ish
I'm thinking the bear could probably get
through these flimsy walls that are
surrounding us well we're pretty sure
looking pretty tasty so we gotta be
careful all right we'll be careful so
good so how do you go about doing this
well I should let me back up even before
we get to how you go about it what got
you here like it did you when you were
10 years old start thinking I want to
understand how audio signals in my ear
turn into abstract thoughts exactly
good for you exactly what I wanted to
know when I was 10 and 12 even 16 yes as
a pubescent boy those were my main
thoughts no I got there completely by
accident or partial accident I am after
college I really wanted to be an actor
or rather a director I really wanted
everybody wanted to direct everything
once be a director I really want to be a
director partially because my wife is an
actress and she was a successful actress
and then we thought well one of us
should have a job so I thought I should
perhaps go to graduate school and I
ended up accidentally in a neuroscience
lab working for a distinguished
neurobiologist at MIT learning how to do
neurophysiology and all the different
using the different tools but in the
back of my head I like language I grew
up in a very multilingual environment
and it was sort of you know something I
had a gut level intuition about and
people at that point said you know
there's a famous language researcher
here you should probably go listen to
some of the lecturers his name is Noam
Chomsky oh oh that's interesting
I'll go to some of those lectures and I
did and that was sort of like somebody
opens the curtains free right you go to
some of those lectures yeah and you
suddenly have a completely different
view of how language can be looked at
studied investigated and it really
that's a that's a game-changing
experience and at that point I decided
to go to graduate school to study and
language works how speech works and then
began to connect it to serve my
interests in biology so right it's
accidental that I'm you know I really
did want to be a director I'm not
kidding I still want to be a director
like you're young you could do it now
I'm a director of a Max Planck Institute
so that sort of counts you know but
Italy does why doesn't count at all I'm
quite have the same vibe
so put Noam Chomsky in perspective for
us since you mentioned him I mean
obviously he's a huge name he's a huge
name not only in the academic field of
linguistics
since psychology but outside so forget
about the outside in the politics my
impression is that my impression is
completely untrustworthy here so I'm
hoping you'll correct it that Chomsky
was extremely influential but there's a
sense of moving beyond him or have we
simply improved upon what do you mean
tell us a little bit what he had to say
and how we think of it today yeah I mean
so so he remains an incredibly
influential and very polarizing figure
so his you know influence derives from
the fact that he really changed how we
do psychology and language sciences and
and philosophy of mind in the mid-50s
based on a series of his early and books
and papers he first of all effectively
got rid of behaviorism and one can even
pinpoint that into those behaviors so
behaviorism was the the dominant view in
psychology for decades before that and
it's a very sort of pleasing and
simplistic view and effectively it boils
down to there's one principle of the
mind which is the principle of
Association okay so it's the basis for
all of the theories of conditioning
conditioning under underlies learning
conditioning underlies effectively all
of behavior so the term behaviorism
became used as a sort of catch-all
phrase for all of psychology and
psychology was based on the principle of
Association now that's a very nice some
have love and his daughter Logan
conditioning operant conditioning and
then of course the most let's say
egregious direction which has went as
Skinner's work so Skinner's BF Skinner
had famously and professor at Harvard
worked on the Skinner box but the
presupposition that you could put your
even your own children and I don't
begrudge him this idea as a father of
three sons nice idea to put them into a
box and train them explicitly to respond
in selective ways to certain stimuli and
so the stimulus response stimulus
response paradigm was the dominant
paradigm for learning memory for
everything in psychology and
neuroscience does some of this I know
this is a tangent but that's okay we
have time the summit is reflect
influence of positivism in the south
that you know rather than looking for
some underlying mechanisms we should
just look at what happens in the world
and describe it as fully as possible and
I think the more sophisticated behaviors
certainly were you know avid readers of
you know Viennese positivism I would
think the D so I think that the most
disturbing part of the story of
behaviorism is that it's still around of
course and deeply and certainly true in
my field in the neurosciences I think
it's actually the default position and
now the influence of Chomsky was to
argue in my view successfully that you
really wanted to have a kind of
Mentalist stance about psychology and
you had a lot of very interesting
arguments he also made a number of very
important contributions to computational
theory to computational linguistics and
obviously to the philosophy of mind and
we're we know we're bracketing his his
political work just interesting but it
separates us completely it's separado I
think he doesn't see it as completely
separate in a principled sense but it is
separate and you know he's as you know
very well known in Europe as a political
dissident in some sense and he's
basically not invited on most US
channels because he's too obnoxious
never yeah of course he's just done here
you see him on TV shows in the
Netherlands but in the u.s. you know
he's on some kind of fringe radio show
in Cambridge Massachusetts or something
yeah but he is that mean he's difficult
I actually just finished a chapter a
couple of you know last year so called
the influence of Chomsky on the
neuroscience of language and because you
know I'm many of us are deeply
influenced by the fact of the matter is
his role has been both deeply important
and moving and terrible and it's partly
because he's so relentlessly undyed
acting if you've ever picked up any of
his writings
he's just it's all about the work I'm
not there to make it bite-size and fun
he assumes a lot a lot of technical
knowledge and a lot of hard work and so
if you're not into that you're never
gonna get past page one because it is
technical but that's made it very
difficult because it's you know it sort
of seems obscurantist to many people
it's always very interesting there's so
many fields where certain people manage
to have huge outside influences
despite being really hard to understand
that's is it partly the cachet of
the reward you feel when you finally do
understand something I mean I wish that
were true that would mean a lot of
people would read it let's say my boring
papers but the I think in the case of
Chomsky it's true because there are
superficial misinterpretations and miss
readings that are very catchy and at
people too so the the you know people
the most famous concept is you know
language is innate right now such a
claim was never made never said it's
much more nuanced it's highly technical
it's about what's the structure of the
learning apparatus what's the nature of
the evidence that the learner gets so
obviously this is a very sophisticated
and nuanced notion but what comes out is
oh that guy's claim is language is
innate and I can remember that and
repeated at cocktail party exactly and
then and that's and that's a little bit
unfortunate because you know that's true
for all fields I mean if there are sort
of nugget sized one-liners they're fun
to remember they're fun to talk about
but they're probably almost always wrong
that's right stuffs complicated yeah
stuff is complicated but so generative
grammar is the other phrase that I
associated with Chomsky all my champion
comes from reading the language instinct
by yeah no I mean so and Steve one of my
professors in graduate school did a you
know remarkable job popularizing the
language sciences and linguistics
although he's himself actually not a
linguist he's a psychologist right that
of course lots of the interpretation of
what people think about Chomsky comes
through the lens of how Pinker wrote
about it and of course that that has its
own interesting flavors right so I mean
Steve's a remarkable writer and and
interesting thinker but you know he has
his own lens yes when one should
probably go to the source and read the
actual material no I'm writing a book
about quantum mechanics right now and
everyone should read it and everything I
say and it is correct but it's not
necessarily what anyone else thought in
the past and even though I try my best
to represent no no I think in your books
of course every word is true that goes
without saying that's it's good to know
there's some people like that but I mean
yeah sometimes I mean especially in the
and let's say technical disciplines you
have to do the hard work and you can't
cut any corners right now so you have to
actually get into the technical notions
and why they were
what are the presuppositions what are
the let's say hypothesized primitives of
a system how do they work together to
generate the phenomena we're interested
in so on so um yeah the concept of
generative grammar very interesting it's
a notion of grammar that's trying to go
away from simply a description or list
of factoids about languages and trying
to say well how is it that you have a
finite set of things in your head I mean
a finite vocabulary and ostensibly
a finite number of possible rules maybe
just one rule who knows but you can
generate and understand an infinite
number of possible things that's the
concept that's typically called discrete
infinity yeah and that's a that's a cool
idea and the idea was to work it out
well if you know if those are the if
that's the parts list how can you have a
system and how can you learn that system
acquire that system how can that system
grow in you and you become a competent
user of it and that's actually subtle
and that's you can't just right so it
requires thinking deeply about well what
is what is actually the parts that's the
architectural e given to you as a human
being having a human brain so in which
sense do we have to be parochial a human
brain has its own properties and which
things are sort of let's say general
properties of the vertebrate right so
those are how do they interact what do
you need is there extra special sauce do
you need God god forbid and things like
that so these are a bit and of course
this has had a tremendous influence on
how we think about the system and how we
study it what kind of methods we can use
and what are the bigger questions but
it's safe to say the mind is not a blank
slate right the brain does have pretty
much pretty much a good bit I think you
can put that one in the band when it
comes to language there is something
what I remember from Pinker is that
there's in some sense a set of switches
in the brain hypothetically which sort
of by learning different languages we
flip one way or another I think that's a
pretty fair way to think about it in a
non-technical you can think of it as
parameters or something like that I know
people think about it in many different
ways but I mean we can certainly assume
that we have a system so look let's back
up for a second suppose we were talking
about the visual system and not writing
language system we wouldn't be having
this discussion because people say
obviously you have you know
system you have it because you're a
vertebrate brain and obviously it
changes in some specifics as a function
of what it what's around you this is not
newsworthy but as soon as we talk
language everyone's an expert everyone
speaks the language everyone has a
powerful intuition and the amount of
nonsense promulgated is a you know
there's a kind of it's astonishing the
level of silliness is kind of no I'm
very sympathetic you know I've written
three popular books so far one on the
nature of time one on the higgs boson
and one on you know the big picture in
the meaning of life by far the best
Amazon reviews or for the Higgs boson
book because no one has a pre-existing
view of the Higgs boson right they're
willing to take what you have to say
about it but they think they know the
meaning of life and they think they know
how time works and if you don't agree
with what they have to say they're not
going to be receptive no no it's it's
it's again there's something about well
in the arts I guess it would be called
connoisseurship yeah right do we still
appreciate the pain in the neck of
having to do the hard work to become a
connoisseur or have technical knowledge
in something and well whatever it takes
a long time it's hard and you might not
get very good at it but it turns out to
be required vitamins if you want to
become really good at knowing the old
masters you know the Netherlands you can
become a connoisseur only if you
actually study it likewise with language
or the brain or physics
well damn sit down do the work yeah so
having said that let's proceed to
drastically oversimplify how the brain
works
let's dress so where did you go after
being inspired by Chomsky and started
studying how the brain processes what we
hear yeah I mean I'd be relatively I
studied a lot of the technical aspects
of language for a while and I became
relatively quickly like everyone else of
my generation I guess seduced by the
possibilities that we now have of
recording from the human brain so when I
was a graduate student about halfway on
in graduate school was the time when the
modern brain imaging machines were
actually first developed and first
rolled out so okay for many years we had
things like x-rays and Kant scans but in
the late 80s and there was a lot of
research using PET scanning it's
positron emission tomography a very
onerous and you know in some sense
invasive technique
to take pictures of the brain while it
was processing something in the in a
complicated way with with a lot of
analytic steps and then the early 90s
there was really a kind of game-changing
event the development of functional
magnetic resonance imaging fMRI we call
it and everybody's probably seen an MRI
machine it's in every hospital if you've
you know blown out your knee or your
shoulder or god forbid if had your head
scanned and those are ubiquitous and
there were a lot of interesting
developments both in the physics of
magnetic resonance and in engineering
and signal processing that allowed us to
begin to use these machines to measure
and quantify the human brain while
something is happening so you're lying
in this it looks like you know I know a
giant hairdryers tube you're lying in
this sausage and it's taking it's really
taking pictures it's called a Tomo
graphic technique where it's an imaging
technique and it was able to take
pictures of which parts of your head
were you know informally speaking active
when you're doing something like
listening to words or listening to a
piece of music or moving your right
finger or looking at a checkerboard
those are the usual experiments and and
what LO is the proxy and they're the
proxy is blood flow or actually blood
oxygenation okay and so that was an
interesting technique because you could
take not completely not invasively like
it's kind of cool imagine you can take a
picture inside someone's head from a
meter away who knew I mean that's you
know with a resolution by the way of
about a millimeter these days about the
resolution so the spatial resolution now
with the machines that we use is on the
order of a millimeter sometimes even
better so you know there are
high-resolution scanners Forex in SATs
seven Tesla which is you know a really
pretty substantial magnetic field and
you can scan things with a resolution
better than one millimeter which is
pretty good but what do you give up for
that wonderful picture you give up
temporal resolution right right so now
you take a really really great picture
of someone's head but the dynamics that
you're able to capture are very very
slow so what have you given up there
well cool picture but know nothing about
the change with the actual online
processing and by the way a cubic
millimeter brain still has a buttload of
neurons
right it's not a buttload or a shit-ton
yeah pens on what your units are but the
you want to be the if you take a a
square millimeter of tissue in the brain
and the cortex and the cerebral cortex
and you look in the cortical column
above right so the cell the tissue
that's directly above a square
millimeter it's it goes up about three
millimeters or so depending on where you
are estimates are that's on the order of
a hundred thousands neurons and that's
just the neurons there's other junk of
the rates so the the parts list of the
brain is very complicated there's lots
of little stuff in there so we vastly
underestimate what's going on in even
you know certainly a cubic millimeter of
cortex we have no idea right okay I mean
it's shameful but anyway you were
mentioning that we also don't have
pinpoint timing of what's yeah so now so
yeah so here things get interesting
because we have to so let's say we want
to you know we're committed to studying
the human brain and there's stuff you
can learn from from animal research very
important stuff and you can do other
kinds of experiments that we can't and
should not do it with people right so
there you can use techniques that have
even higher spatial resolution even
higher temporary solution but you know
except for very extreme medical cases
those are not appropriate so we have to
use non-invasive techniques so you're
talking about things where animals are
sacrificing themselves at the claws of
science yes and then in very important
ways and and you know if you've ever
gone to the dentists then you should be
very grateful for the research if you've
taken now there are you know this is a
very politically sensitive and
complicated topic like what extent do we
support animal research I'm a hundred
percent and Susie a stickily in favor of
careful responsible ethically executed
well-managed
animal research there is no alternative
for it and there are currently wild and
scary debates about this in Europe in
particular more active than in the
United States and they're quite terrible
and they're they're you know the debates
the debates are irrational vitriolic and
dangerous and they are leading to a
sharp reduction in you know careful
animal research so of course it's not
necessary for you know as far as
I'm concerned for let's say and
cosmetics for sampling that shampoos
forget that right bits there you know to
understand basic principles of
physiology and we have no alternative
and I think would be you know a very
peculiar stance not to advance that so
so but at this point we do not take
human subjects and probably open their
brains we do not and we should not and
so we have so there are wonderful new
techniques that are used and you know
everyone talks about them optogenetics
is a particularly exciting one you can
treat cells you can inject the cells
with particular and light activated
molecules such that you can then control
their activity but you can't do that
with people you can record single cells
for in animals but you can only do it
under rare conditions in humans for
example during epilepsy surgery but so
look we have non-invasive techniques
that are amazing I mean they're so we
can take MRI pictures of your brain but
then we're sacrificing time and if you
don't believe time matters you how fast
do you think our conversation is going
right answer our conversation if you
measured it and the mean rate of speech
across languages by the way it's
independent of languages between four
and five Hertz right so the amplitude
modulation of the signal so the signal
is a wave you have to imagine that
there's any signal to the speech signal
in particular is a wave that just goes
up and down in amplitude or informally
speaking in loudness right so the signal
goes up and down and the speech signal
goes up and down four to five times a
second what do you what is the speech
signal gene this is what your brain so
the speech signal is the stuff that
comes out of your mouth okay okay right
so I'm saying your computer is gray that
is a let's say that was two-and-a-half
seconds of speech it came out of my
mouth as a waveform and that's the way
form that vibrates your ear your eardrum
good more just cool but if you look at
the amplitude of that waveform right
it's a it's signal amplitude going up
and down it's actually now you know this
is this is not debated it's four to five
times per second this is a fact about
the world which is pretty interesting so
the speech rate is or the so called
modulation spectrum of speeches as four
to five Hertz is it very different for
different mammals
it's a good question we don't know so
much about that because nobody vocalizes
as much as we do it's probably a little
different because it has to do with sort
of the cortical processing rate and of
course the biomechanics of the
articulator so it's likely be a little
different
music incidentally has a modulation
spectrum that's a little bit slower it's
about 2 Hertz so that's equivalent to
roughly 120 beats per minute which was
pretty cool
favorite number yeah so a favorite
number really comes out when you do the
physics of signals if you think you know
dozens and dozens of hours of music and
you calculate what is the mean you know
across different genres what is the mean
rate that the signal goes up and down
it's 2 Hertz
cool cool fact I remember it that
science
besides salad up so speech happens very
fast and in that rate so if if our mouth
opens four to five times per second
that's not fast enough yet because of
course inside those that's roughly the
rate of syllables but syllables have
internal structure so that means it's
must it must be going even faster faster
than 100 milliseconds so if you really
want to understand what's going on as
stuff comes into your head whether it's
hearing or vision or touch you need
devices that can measure things at the
rate of milliseconds you know or tens of
milliseconds a thousandth of a second
that's absolutely necessary because
that's the speed at which our mind and
our perceptual apparatus works so there
are other tools that we and this MRI was
an fMRI as time resolution is on the
order of at best a second okay but more
likely you know seconds five second one
five times improvement so now we need
different machines so we need so we have
one kind of machine like MRI that takes
really detailed pictures in space but
has miserable temporal resolution on the
other hand there are other tools the
most well known one is
electroencephalography it's been around
since the 1920s and that has is those
are electrical techniques so they have
very good temporal resolution so you can
measure things at the outside of the
head using electrodes and and yeah now
you have very very high temporal
resolution as high as you want depends
on your processor let's say 1,000
samples per second right so really so
every millisecond you um measure the
data that's still very low for some
processes and physics a that would be
ultra slow we're
pepto seconds yeah but you know between
friends with example if it's a few
orders of magnitude and so you want to
pair you want to have those machines to
rights because you want a sense
processing as fast you want to be able
to understand well how does you know
what's actually happening at those
timescales and for that my own favorite
technique is one called magneto
encephalography and that measures the
magnetic fields generated by current
flow in your brain and it's the most
sensitive technique we have to measure
the human brain non-invasively it looks
like a giant hair dryer and that giant
hair dryer has little and detectors in
it typically then they you don't see
them obviously they're inside the hair
dryer and they're swimming in liquid
helium to keep them at superconducting
temperature and they're little coils and
let's say there's about you know 150
above them inside in surrounding your
head and then you can measure the brain
activity at let's say millisecond
resolution and reconstruct as best you
can how fast and where things happen so
you really want to pair these different
techniques if you have one have an
increasingly comprehensive thing and I
remember not that long ago I stuck you
into one of those missions I was in in
fact I got a lot of mileage out of it I
was stuck I stuck your head into an M eg
miss Eugenia and we measured your brain
response to different tones and a few
visual stimuli and it turns out your
brain worked you confirmed the existence
of my brain very Happ so that so the
news was good Internet has mixed reviews
on the existence of my brain so I was
glad you could compare we found all the
parts and no extra parts exactly so it's
all good
and I like it especially because there's
physics right the reason why you could
get the signal is because a thought is
manifested by charged particles being
accelerants right and that's where the
magnetic field comes from it's amazing
again amazing that it works right so I
mean the the you know the fact that we
can have a conversation is a mechanical
wave vibrating your ear which turns into
electricity in your auditory periphery
which sends a signal using a code we
don't yet understand into different
parts of your brain where it's decode
where it's decoded or represents
information using some code that we also
don't know
and using electricity which flows around
generating magnetic fields yeah I mean
it's wild out there you have a lot to do
a lot of science what are you cool that
it worked that we can do it at all
suggests that you know using the you
know insights and tools of physics and
the sort of the toolbox of physiology is
the best way to go and you know if you
have a theory that's my that's well
there's other tool that's the neck is
going to be some ideas we have learned
something by doing all these things
right we've changed how we think about
how languages process it's not just
maybe we can do this we've made progress
we've made I think good progress and you
know I would say and it's very hard to
measure in this area of research what
would constitute compelling progress
right what Sutton what universe would be
say holy cow
we have a true explanation we got it
once and for all yeah and partly that
has to do with what do we think is an
explanation and that's a very
complicated concept in its own right
whether you're thinking but from the
point of view of philosophy the sciences
you know sort of an epistemological idea
but we do have let's say what we have
for sure as better descriptions if not
better explanations and the descriptions
have changed quite a bit and that beings
and I don't know what the timescale is
that would count as success but I think
it's we can sort of say that we've had
the same paradigm for we've had the same
neurobiological paradigm for about a
hundred and fifty years since Broca and
wanaka since the 1860s actually a very
straightforward idea you know so that's
older than electromagnet is yes that's a
major and then and that should where are
you it's always in statistical mechanics
and and so what should worry about that
is that that model is still so what is
that model let me tell you I mean the
idea was well language is a some Faculty
of the mind it lives whatever that means
in the left hemisphere typically so the
model says so the model says and there
is a blob on the front part of your
brain and the frontal lobe on the left
side and there's another blob of tissue
and the posterior part of your brain and
the
they're connected by a wire which as the
charming name arcuate fasciculus and
that's what you get you've got an area
for production an area for comprehension
and a wire that connects the two and if
you go and there's a couple extra wires
but they're not you know they're not
talked about much if you go to classic
neurology textbooks now and if you have
a stroke the chances are probably better
than you know ten to one that the
neurologists examining you will refer to
that figure and that model and that
really should worry you and was that
model based on people dissecting human
brain it was not that model was based on
what really in some sense the oldest
model in neuroscience it was based on
patient data famously the patient a guy
named Lou Bonilla or known in the
literature as tall and Broca who was a
neurologist in Paris right had D and
examined him tested him behaviorally
came and noticed that the guy couldn't
say much remarkably a few days after he
gave him a thorough examination the man
died and was able to do you know huh why
did that never works out that way so you
know they found correlations so it's
it's what's called no deficit lesion
correlation so they found a lesion and
this patients brain and broke out in
this case and was able to correlate it
with the particular behavioral deficits
that look as interesting if this part of
the brain is broken and this behavior is
broken there must be a some kind of
causal relationship between a particular
brain area and the function it executes
now that's a very reasonable hypothesis
I mean subject to subtle things one
could change about it but it's very a
bit it seems like a good start that's a
good some years later and the German
neurologists Val nikka made a similar
discovery for a different brother brain
he found patients that had a lesion or
in a brain injury due to stroke in the
posterior part of the brain in the
temporal lobe and and that patient or
those patients had trouble understanding
that where they could talk they were
very fluent but didn't make any sense so
the assumption was okay so the
and bird is broken so we have a
production art and a comprehension part
and so now we have a kind of
understanding now what's the problem
with that well first of all that's not a
theory of language for that we had to
wait another hundred years until
language the language sciences were more
mature and there the work of Chomsky in
the eighteen and the nineteen fifties
played an enormous role but for those
hundred years from 1861 to let's say
1961 the theory of language that was at
the basis of how we think about brain
and language was pretty naive I mean
know something we could come up with
right now with a piece of paper and a
pen and that's of course it's amazing
how powerful that model was and how hard
it was to get to get beyond it but now
we've known for sorry remind me what
about the two blobs can isolate so
there's an area called Broca's region
right so Broca's area named after the
neurologists Paul Broca an area called
vadym a cos region after the
neurologists khalid vannacutt and then
why or a set of wires really in between
called the arcuate fasciculus so that's
basically tissue can you know those are
literally the wires connecting the one
blob to the other and the idea is well
at the root you have the role of the two
aryan role of the two areas as one is
for production and one's for
comprehension okay got it
very simple idea and very elegant very
elegant is only the world if only the
world were also aligned to you know so
models are doomed to be true for a while
then so in this case and this is very
powerful because it has the elegance of
simplicity but it also is empirically
wrong
so it's wrong for many reasons patience
but the different lesions turned out not
to have those syndromes the brain
organization is much more complicated
the wiring diagram is you know because
aliens have trying to be more
complicated so we've known for certainly
40 years that it's incorrect and now in
the last ten years I'm happy to say and
there are you know a handful of models
and that really go well beyond that and
it show us actually how long the parts
list is and how much more complicated
the structure is partly that's because
these contemporary models are much more
in tune with what we know about the
biology of the human brain and likewise
what we know about the psychology of
human language so they try to
the you know let's say models of
linguistics and psycholinguistics -
models of Neurobiology
and surely there has inadequate but
hopefully they're wrong in an
interesting way and they are you know
the fact of the state of the art right
now one hopes for progress not for
definitiveness especially that's a good
brain that's a nice way to say it yes
I'm gonna think you know so look the
brains a complicated place you work on
big things really really really big
places and so the place I work on is
small by comparison it's just the size
of two fists really together that being
said my small place is pretty
complicated way more complicated it has
a hundred million hearts right and has
about so the current estimate for the
human brain is has 86 billion cells and
each cell has you know if you think
about it serve in the Facebook sense
each cell has between 1000 and 10,000
friends so are they really friends
though there's likes there's how sure we
really kara's out but then if you
imagine that their course you know
communicating with each other
electrically and chemically the
computational complexity of the prop
gets out of hand in a hurry right this
is one of the reasons we don't really
have you know the kinds of theories that
are that are successful inadequate at
the moment right but we do so you are
part of the originator of something
called the dual stream model so you
complicated at the simple model a little
bit by imagining it there there's more
than one thing going on is it possible
to simplify that enough to podcast sure
I mean so that's of course the correct
model we know know so that was an
attempt by a colleague of mine Greg
Hickok and me we've worked together on
this kind of thing for many years trying
to bring together data from patients
right patients with stroke and imaging
in biology and linguistics to come up
with a much more and let's say
biologically realistic computationally
explicit and Lee and theoretically well
motivated idea and what we really did is
and we borrowed or what let's say we
adopted and adapted the standard model
of vision and
so in the standard model so what do you
have to do when you see something the
most straightforward way to think about
vision is you have to locate things and
then you want to know what they are
right so there's a where system and a
what system and that's you know actually
not that much of a simplification as it
turns out so there's a whole chunk of
brain tissue that you know the human
brain the vertebrate brain has enormous
amounts dedicated to the visual system
and so there's an enormous amount
dedicated to and processes that identify
objects the so called what system and
they go along as it turns out the
temporal lobe and their job so this is
sort of the side of the brain under your
ears and these series of regions of
which there are dozens actually are
their job is to extract the information
that lets you actually identify things
so how do I know this is a glass of
water that's a glass of wine this is a
chair that's a hawk flying by rights you
have to identify the object that's super
useful you kind of want that however you
also want another thing you need to know
where is it relative to where you are so
you need a system that allows you for
instance to regulate your eye movements
figure out where you're reaching to grab
something see that a saber-toothed tiger
is coming from the left and not the
right so vision has really worked us out
in wonderful detail you know a very very
elegant and we so we we have one stream
principally responsible for localization
information other things as well but in
the that's sort of a good summary
statement and another stream of another
anatomic stream with sub areas
responsible for identifying objects very
cool idea until you sub by the way
you've now bought yourself an
interesting problem how do you put them
together well it's gonna say it could
have been that there's really only one
system that did both functions but it's
two different systems both sort of
operationally but also literally where
they are in the brain yeah they're
literally a different streams of
information yeah and so this was
discovered a long time ago in the 60s in
the hamster actually and so this notion
of multiple and sensory areas and
multiple different streams responsible
for in some sense it's an engineering
idea that you then see replicated in the
brain right so you want sort of sub
SPECT
as a ssin because the circuitry in those
areas really does things optimized for
that thing right so you want to you know
let's say you want to really identify an
object you want to have very high
spatial resolution you really want to be
able to see the details analyze its
surface make guesses about a heavy it is
and so on whereas you don't care so much
when you just need to let's say move
your eyes to the right to run away or
something like so so that's special so
we basically stole that idea and we're
in the best scientific in the sense of
adopting and adapting and said well what
if the the speech and language system
actually did something that's not that
dissimilar capitalizing on similar
computations right so the visual system
is pretty old but it's pretty useful it
does so one of the things you have to do
in the language case is you know what do
you want from the information you have
but one of the things you want is the
content the what so I need to recognize
words I need to string words together to
recognize this meaning so you know I
need to be able to tell the difference
between dog bites Sean and Sean by its
dog which would be enough I'm cool yeah
I try so those are the same same set of
words but they mean something completely
different so you need to actually so you
know in this case the particular
ordering has a clear consequence for the
interpretation and so we we reasoned
that maybe the brain is organized or
capitalizes on the same computational
principles is you have one stream of
information says look what I really need
to do is figure out what am I actually
hearing what are the words how do I put
them together and how do i extract
meaning from that and you have another
stream that really needs to be able to
deal with well how do I translate that
into an output stream so let's say let's
call it a house stream or an
articulatory interface so why why would
you do such a thing
well let's take a the simplest case of a
word and so what's a word well you know
word is not a technical concept by the
way we're deserve an informal concept as
you remember from your reading of Steve
bankers book so the technical term here
would be morpheme the smallest meaning
bearing unit but we'll call them words
words roughly correspond to ideas yeah
so what is the word so you have a word
it comes in so my word that comes in
into your head now
let's say computer and as it comes in
you have to link that sound file to the
concept in your head right so it comes
in your translated into a code we don't
know let's say you know Microsoft brain
and you then translate that code then
gets linked somehow to the file that is
the storage of the word computer in your
head now in your head somewhere there's
a file an address that says the word
computer what it means for you like I oh
you know I'm on deadline you know oh
this file goddamn my email crashed but
there's many other things so you know
what it means you know how to pronounce
it you know a lot about computers but
you also know how to say it right so it
also has to have an articulatory code
now here comes the rub the articulatory
code is in a different coordinate system
and all the other ones because it's in
the motor system so it's in basically
time and in motor people called joint
space because you move articulate or you
move your jaw your tongue your lips so
the coordinate system that use as a
controller is quite different than the
other ones so you have to have areas of
the brain that go back and forth
seamlessly and very quickly because
speech is fast between an articulatory
coordinate system for speaking and an
auditory coordinate system for airing
and some coordinate systems yet
unspecified but you wouldn't understand
at all for meaning so you're screwed so
even something banal like you know
knowing the word computer or glass or
milk or is already a deeply complicated
theoretical problem so in the visual
case the dual streams if we call that
okay they're simply called the what and
where but the dual stream is simply that
you subdivide problems in the multiple
streams right like an engineer would but
those particular streams are what things
are and where they are and in the audio
case the hearing case it's what they
mean well it's let's say we call an
interface to the meaning system you know
that's a structure and meaning and an
interface to the motor system so we call
it a words yeah for example I mean right
so that we called it a sound - meaning
interface and a sound - articulation
interface it does sound like it's a
slightly different problem in the sense
that language
is where these meanings come from or at
least often you know sometimes we just
Yelp or scream or whatever but in the
visit the vision problem seems much more
straightforward right like any
vertebrate is gonna want to know where
things are and what they are we humans
have a special problem when it comes to
sound which is that we want to interpret
these in much more abstract ways yeah I
mean the it's quite true that you don't
want to over analogize here I mean the
and there are aspects of this which we
which to me seemed quite different right
so one of the main things we do in the
language case is what's technically
called compositionality right so it's
just to take things and put them
together and that's not so obvious how
that's drew in the vision case although
it may be I don't want to over you know
state my case here but the kinds of
things you have to do in language and
vision are different and certainly the
output systems are different right so
you know the eye movement system is not
like the speech system or something like
that but what you could imagine is that
certain of the subroutines that are
executed in the way there are shared
remember that so for instance that's a
very common evolutionary strategy that's
right the brain is always borrowing the
bodies always that's exact you want to
basically recycle stuff right so so one
reason that that Gregg cacar can I
argued for this particular dual stream
position ours is now one of a few I mean
there's a handful of these I think there
are you know we of course things ours is
still the best though that's not ten
years old but now it's actually but the
fact of one of this I'll tell you is a
fun sociological story about that in a
second but the so one of the things and
that might be shared is this notion of
let's say a coordinate transformation so
the reason I very I'm very attached to
this is because the same part of the
brain that we argue does this for the
language speech case with speech
perception to production sensory motor
cases that you have to do a similar
thing in the eye movement case so if you
take the problem I mean here's a simple
problem that everybody can do for
themselves right now you're sitting
while you're listening to this
magnificent podcast you have a glass of
wine in front of you and we do by the
way which we do and I now really want to
reach for this class
one terrific read one by the way and so
what I have to do to execute that you
know ostensibly simple thing so the
first thing is they glass falls onto my
eye ball into my retina in particular
right so the surface and the back of my
eye that does the initial encoding and
so the coordinates of that our retina
centric right so that is a particular
two-dimensional sheet and the glass is
now falling somewhere on that sheet and
the information now goes in into my head
but now note that I can move my eyes so
now it's no longer in the coordinates of
the retina but in the accordance of the
eyeball now I can move my head I can
also move my trunk but in the end what
I'm trying to do is reach for the damn
glass of wine so it has to be in
coordinates that are relative to my
trunk and to my arm right so because I'm
going to reach my arm out and it needs
to be I need to have knowledge of where
is my current position of my hand where
does my hand need to be how hard does my
hand need to grasp so the simple act of
reaching for a glass of wine or a pencil
or anything ever requires a series of
transformations conceptually right so
that doesn't mean you're doing a series
of equations right there but you may be
but you need to transform the
information into a suitable format and
so if it comes in in i centered
coordinates and has to go out in hand
centered or muscle centered coordinates
what gives how do you know that doesn't
come for free so the regions of the
brain that do that in the posterior part
of the parietal lobe but different part
more on the top of your head likely are
optimized for that kind of computation
and we reasoned well look I mean if
that's the same kind of mathematical
problem maybe that's really well
implemented there and maybe the speech
problem is similar in kind
now obviously the inputs and outputs are
quite different you're going to get
let's say you know informally speaking a
sound file in and some kind of motor
command out but the kind of problem is
the same kind of problem you have to
have some kind of basis function you
have to transform it into a different
thing so that's why we borrowed the
thing from vision and tried to say well
this is computationally similar and
that's why we're we think this sort of
constitutes a form of progress
because we try to be explicit right
about the set of operations that you
really do have to do in order to achieve
what's ostensibly almost idiotically
simple but you know the bottom line is
we do not know how we recognize a single
word or a single object I do have a
question but first I'm using
sociological story you probably okay
Farren so I this is this is kind of how
science sometimes works and you know it
has funny parts and slightly less than
music but when so about ten or maybe by
now 15 years ago when Greg Hickok and I
started working this out one of the
things we argued for was this dual
stream concept another thing we argued
for was that things really are much more
bilaterally organized and at that point
we were still extremely young well um
younger than now now you're only mostly
you know I'm just you know a little more
mature the so Greg and I wrote the stuff
up and we sent it to an or the initial
reaction to our work was that we were
basically crazy because there was a
model from the 19th century it worked it
was clinically useful and we were
accused of being you know charlatans and
the most naive bunch of Yahoo's who
didn't know the first thing about any of
the relevant disciplines which you know
kind of bummed us out yeah like to hear
that right you were like okay no we were
just reading the literature and doing
our work and I mean it's true that we
departed pretty drastically from the
standard model at that point but we
thought we were being very you know
motivated by vision thinking about
linguistics thinking about the biology
of the brain people basically dismissed
as a complete nut jobs the problem is
that people who sound like complete nut
jobs if you do have a tremendously
important breakthrough the changes of
the world you will be told you're a
complete nut job but most people who
sound like complete nut jobs do not have
tremendously important breakthroughs
that well yeah there's yeah I mean we
were so we thought we were being pretty
careful in our reasoning now so of
course our feelings were because we're a
young we were both I think assistant
professors at that point and our
feelings were hurt understandably and
but then ironically so you know people
started saying well maybe that's maybe
they're not so stupid the data started
amassing and you know the people start
really thinking about it reading it and
go
a lot of attention to this thing and now
10 years or 15 years later it's become
more or less a standard thing and it's
now it is the textbook model but now
ironically all the young people stand up
and basically take shots at us about how
naive and how stupid or what so we never
had the good years right never worthy
initially we were the cranks who were
just didn't know and now we're just like
the old guard you know who just really
isn't on the cutting edge and we're
outdated even for you where we were so
so sometimes we serve a little wistfully
things like when don't we ever get a
break here do we you know people get the
answer is no you do not get a break you
do not get a break so that was I mean
we're obviously happy that people are
interested in this but it would have
been nice to have like two years were to
say good for you you know a nice idea
it's probably wrong but good for you I
know it well but I'm thinking you know
is it there is there an obstacle to
understanding both vision and auditory
signals that we kind of in the back of
our minds know a little bit too much
about how computers work like when we
take a picture with a camera
we have pixels and we imagine there's
just data of where things are and what
color they are and the brain is much
more based on extrapolations from
incomplete data of both in speech and in
vision is that is that getting in the
way of solving this important problem of
how we go from the basic input stream to
the meaning inside well I think you um I
think that's not quite right that is to
say the pixel or camera metaphor for
vision is also wrong all right so just
as a hearing and language car engine is
entirely constructive process so is
vision in the brain it is yeah I'm
saying for camera for camera it's not
there so we're taking the camera analogy
so we don't want to take that too far
right I mean what we do know and we've
known and effectively since I want to
say him oh it's probably earlier and why
it's always right about most things yes
most there's a there's a good line but I
want to say David Hubel Dee and Nobel
laureates
and winning neuroscientists who
discovered fundamental principles of the
early visual cortex he and Torsten
Wiesel won the Nobel Prize in 1981 and I
think it's a
remember hearing this in a lecture that
and David Hubel gave many years ago
thing most of what we do are footnotes
to Helmholtz very nice which I thought
was sort of you know cribbing moralize
can be pretty cool
no Emerson's lying that philosophy is
just footnotes to Plato yes that's where
you get yeah so I mean I think that the
the notion that it's entirely
constructed right so this is a that you
need a kind of computational seer using
the word computation a little bit
loosely I think is now completely
convincing all right so that it's that
the way we do things are predictive for
instance that most of what we do is it
prediction that the data that you get
are you know vastly under determine the
the percepts and experience that you and
that you extract from the initial data
and so that it's a it's a filling in
process right so you take under
specified data and that are probably
noisy anyway and then you build a
internal representation that you use for
inference and use for action those are
the two things you presumably want to do
most I mean you want to not run into
things and you want to think about stuff
and so there I think my life not saying
something about sit that's yeah we all
have the same issue that I often succeed
mistakes
I think poorly and but the so I think
that the there is now for many years the
start I mean this actually brings us
back for document earlier the influence
of Chomsky and mentalism was the
embracing of what was and still is
called the computational theory of mind
and very influential I mean I think
people like Fodor played an enormous
role in this and subsequent you know
Jerry Fodor the philosophy area this
philosopher Jerry Fodor and then
subsequently people like Dan Dennett
picked it up in as its you know de facto
as far as I can tell the most reasonable
way to think about the mind you know
barri I mean there are no alternatives I
find even vaguely credible not that
they're not all over the interwebs yeah
but these are men so these are extremely
and what has made these helpful is the
the requirement to make things explicit
and sort of procedure and to think a
little bit like a program I mean really
spell out what are the in some sense it
stay
King work on the mind and brain which I
don't take to be particularly different
just like any other discipline biology
or physics that is to say your first job
is to identify the parts list right I
mean what is the ontological structure
of your domain
what are actually the primitives you
might call or I just like to go out the
parts lists it's less complicated
sounding what are the smallest elements
that you need to use to generate the
phenomena and then you need to identify
the forces or the interactions between
the primitives that generate the
phenomena under study and that's and the
the computational theories might have
been very good about that now the quest
there obviously one can do better
because we don't what the primitives are
is a research program just like in
physics it takes decades and decades we
don't know what the smallest pieces are
right because it turns out to be really
difficult every time we look it's a
little bit smaller it's changed a little
bit or it's you know for example now if
you ask someone well what do you think
is the relevant part of their brain
they're gonna say it's a neuron that's a
nice idea that's but maybe it's a sub
part of a sub part of a neuron or it
could turn out that it's gonna be five
neurons wired up a certain way namely
tore a capacitor and ones already know
who the hell knows we simply don't know
what the encoding of information is well
even for the neurons it's progress right
in the sense that I get the impression
that in at some point in the history of
psychology it was thought that there you
know the brain was a bunch of blobs
interacting with each other and just the
progress that has been made by thinking
of it as a network right of neurons and
they're not all connected to each other
equally there's some hierarchical
structure there yeah that look I mean
that's that brings a very interesting
and a slightly dodgy point right so the
UM now nobody would argue that that the
network metaphor isn't necessary and
important research agenda that being
said isn't that just kicking the can
down the road and before you said well
it's this part of tissue and we don't
understand now you say well it's five
pieces of tissue with a bunch of wires
interacting and we don't understand
those so I'm so simply saying well it's
a network is it's kind of punting on the
problem for me it's a tiny little thing
I
so it is very so that look I mean we're
all on board with it obviously everybody
agrees look it's a super complicated
dynamic system with many interacting
parts we're trying to figure out how
this you know the extremely high
dimensional dynamics of the things work
but it's a bit it's me not a mechanistic
answer sure it's a metaphoric extension
not um it's a metaphor another
mechanisms to say it's a knit well how
far does so there has been progress made
how far does that get us to the stated
goal of understanding what happens when
we hear words like freedom or love you
know words that are not referring to
objects out there that we can point at a
tactical it's very difficult question I
mean the vast majority of standard work
truly say refers to let's say the so
called open class items or you know
nouns and verbs
you know chairs and dogs and bears and
things like that and no bears yet by the
way no Bears although some deer often
over there and maybe brought them to New
York the so the property of abstraction
is particularly difficult because um you
no longer want to deal with things like
oh this concept has a bunch of features
that make them and you know these
necessary and sufficient features make
you a member of the category honesty
right the now there are such ideas
namely the concept of embodied cognition
very very popular these days in
psychology and neuroscience I can't say
that I find it coherent but it certainly
you know be my guest
and work it out and then I'll watch the
movie it's all good but the it gets even
more gnarly when you think not just
about abstract concepts so so how does
the let's you know vacuum for ones and
how does thought partition roughly you
might say well there are concrete things
that we think about like dogs cats and
tables and you know the untutored
intuitions as well those are the easy
ones yeah it's not easy either then
there is abstract that they're not
easier or just not easy they're not easy
and they're not easier there's no reason
to believe that the way we understand
cat
easier than the way we understand to
honesty okay I have no reason to believe
that all right right so we have
intuitions that my gosh I cannot
understand honesty at all I know that
but I don't know if your cat also
doesn't understand Cat Cat actually no
but I mean there so there are there are
of course in our world concrete things
that we that we reason about there are
abstract things that we make inferences
about but then there are the real juicy
bits which is these small lists of words
and all our languages so-called closed
class items that make you know make it
all worthwhile namely things like end or
right under through not yeah and that's
where the fun begins so how are the and
those are the ones you really want to
understand because that's actually the
glue that holds the stuff together right
so you don't say cat dog I mean unless
you're a phasic actually but I mean what
you really say is you know no I don't
want that quinoa right you know past the
gluten rich pasta so but you're sounding
pessimistic you're sounding like well at
least well no I'm realistic about that
so I'm trying to say look you know I'm
not I'm not pessimistic about where I
think we've made wonderful progress and
I think that sort of we're piecing this
stuff slowly together but I'm a little
and and actually okay so here's what I'm
up to mystic and pessimistic about I'm
optimistic about that we can get a grip
on let's say in the next 10 years the
let's call them rules or operations or
computations that put items together to
yield larger items so the fact that and
red can for instance is a can and not a
red right how'd you know that yeah that
doesn't follow from first principle you
have to actually figure that out right
so that's actually you know that that's
not a gimme
right and the M so but my hunch is that
these sort of elementary operations of
composition or combinatorics that yields
larger units that then become the input
to the next steps I'm actually pretty
optimistic about that we're gonna get a
grip on that believe it or not okay what
I'm much more we're not pessimistic but
just kind of
bewildered about and there's stuff that
I think that's giving me more you know
there's stuff that I think about a lot
is well how do you store anything to
begin with so if I say red can that's
great but where is red
where's can and how to put red can
together so the literally literally
located in the brain such that so the
the remarkable thing is as we talked
about earlier you have let's say you
have 50,000 or your uber educated so you
probably have a hundred thousand things
in your head right now any of them are
silly and use many of them useless but
but even the useless ones you pull it at
the rate that our conversation is
happening we said you know four to five
Hertz is a typical syllable rate that
means we speak you know something
between three to five words per second
super fast so it means at that time
scale you have to translate the
information coming into the periphery
into the correct code go into your bag
of words pull out the correct item not
the wrong item we're pretty good right
compared to machines are unbelievably
robust and resilient and noise and all
kind of stuff pull out the right item
and keep doing that sequentially put
them together with the next one
and also with ones that are distant and
get the correct interpretation out at a
scale at a sub-second scale all the time
right I mean that is so the operations
that happen I'm pretty optimistic about
that we get a grip on because we're I
think there's wonderful research
happening of that in many different labs
it's the process of the identification
of how we actually store not just words
but anything at all is to me deeply
puzzling and I think is one of the
deepest mysteries of neuroscience and I
always I would have thought at the most
naive level again perhaps being misled
by the analogy with computers that
information is stored in individual
neurons as some bits somewhere like
there's a computer memory my
understanding is that that is wrong and
neuroscientists will tell me that it's
closer to being stored in the
connections between the neurons but
maybe you're gonna tell me that we don't
even know that and so that's yeah you're
absolutely right so I much prefer your
first story that you say
another may that maybe things are stored
inside cells or the structures of cells
or even possibly the genome but the that
would be the really interesting case how
do color red I can learn the color red
and it will be stored in my well know
what I mean what do you have all the
introns for I mean we don't know but
look the standard story is the one you
just said so our standard story in
memory right now is it's the connections
between cells as the synaptic structure
and the synaptic connectivity is what
reflects memory of something and the
modification of that connection between
cells effectively what learning means so
learning means a modification a cellular
molecular level modification and
ultimately a genetic level modification
right and Nobel Prizes have been giving
out but giving out numerous right so
this is yes I mean so that you know the
first one perhaps you know kandel most
famously for a note for this synaptic so
the synaptic pattern of things is the
basis of this and this is you know this
is the standard story but when you start
to dig in a little bit and I think the
most most um that's a harsh critic is is
Randy galas tell from the from Rutgers
and who's a very distinguished
psychologist and cognitive scientist
who's worked most of his life on
learning actually and from a
computational point of view I was
written a very very fascinating book
called memory and the computational
brain okay and a bunch of papers in
which he basically it pulls the rug out
from under neuroscience of memory and
says look you know show me at least how
you store the number 17 or something or
anything for that matter yeah where and
where is it how is it done and then how
is it actually implemented when you use
it how do you so we have sort of
intuitions that yes the pattern of
connectivity maybe you know activated or
deactivated but you really need some
kind of digital storage device right so
I mean the issue that's very tricky in
memory is you on the one hand so the way
human memory works is certainly content
addressable we know that for words for
instance right so it's content
addressable and sense of us a doctor you
think nurse or Toothaker you
whatever the appropriate semantic field
is that that associates with you so that
that's what content addressability is
right so there's a content-based sort of
cloud of ideas but you also want what a
computer has which is address address
ability right as you go to a location
and you pull something at and so how do
we so is that possible
can we put things there how would we
store in a sort of digital format the
digital information we have how do we
actually compute let's say with
variables I mean take that might you
know the wonderful examples from you
know the animal world deep Tunisian
desert and cut that goofus okay right so
lives in desert Tunisia flat not much to
see right
no visual cues the ant walk comes out of
its burrows and comes out and it has to
walk around to finally say leaf right so
the ant has to these ants are small not
huge brains dant walks around walks
around meandering you know maybe a meter
2 meters finds a bit of leaf how does
the ant walk back straight back to its
hole how how does the ant know how to do
that ok so how would you do that or and
so you don't have to figure out a bit of
math you have to figure out ok wait and
wait a minute so here's a simple one it
doesn't like Hansel and Gretel so it
leaves a little bit of chemical trail
but if it did that it would wander back
the same path it doesn't do that it
actually takes a kind of straight vector
back and then looks for its hold so it
must have first of all figured out how
far it went so that's that you count the
steps or something yeah which turns out
it does it has to keep track of time
because at that point the Sun has of
course changed position so it needs to
solar ephemeris function yeah so you
need to actually have an equation in
your head in which you plug in the value
of variables that you then calculate in
order to say I have to go back you know
South by Southwest and you know yay much
you know whatever for feet now that's a
kind of simple example well attested in
beautiful experiments by the way but
that's a kind of compelling you know in
very clear case where a small nervous
system has to take you know does a very
simple behavior namely finding your home
after walking out but in order to do
that it has to plug a
you into a variable so high but abstract
right now things get many your high
school students struggle not enjoy this
concept and so how does the little tiny
brain have represented a variable that
then is able to take a specific value
than do its little calculation in Samuel
and that way this is this the experiment
where they put the little ants on still
this is exactly one of them yeah there's
a whole bunch of experiments they these
are mostly Bo who dig Avena from foolish
and beautiful beautiful experiments and
when they were on stilts they got the
wrong answer because they took the
number of steps but they didn't
understand how far they were going
exactly right so that was the evidence
that they you have a counter because if
you're too high and you take the number
you would go too far so area so but that
it makes us such a compelling case for a
simple kind of computation so if Santa
is that it can't be impossible yeah so
there is circuitry in a small brain that
allows you to have variable based
computations right no if you attribute
it to the end
do you not attribute it to the
vertebrate right that seems weird to me
and you're hinting that this might be
part of the origin of abstraction well I
mean what I really that's already too
far man I think I would like to you know
to me it's a sort of reminder that one
of the things we have to have an answer
for is um computation let's say
algebraic computation yeah so I mean
it's actually good to have a tractable
goal right so okay so if we can
understand that which in some primitive
sense even ants can do it that would be
nice yeah I mean it gives a very
specific and so it's the kind of problem
that the you know that language faces
too so for instance look I mean one of
the interesting things about language
processing is that it's the so called
property of structure dependence right
so one of the things that makes
computers different from you know human
brains is for the most part I mean so is
that I'm sure the the way the language
works across all languages it's not a
string of pearls but it's more like an
Alexander Calder mobile right so it has
some relationships that are dependent on
where in a structure things are now it's
just in a sequence so it's not just you
know I have a sentence that has seven
words one two three four five six seven
in a row
oh and it matters what is your neighbor
your nears but it matters what their
structural relation is and there's you
know there's sort of incontrovertible
evidence for this is not debated right
so this notion of that means you have to
have some kind of yeah some people give
it a kind of tree structure because
that's a good way to visualize it other
people are deeply offended by trees and
they say but you can't have trees living
in the brain and but that's just a
notational variant of you can express
that many different ways I mean networks
people will love it come that reserve or
it can be bracketing like in a bra or
whatever I mean could call whatever you
want it's just that their relations are
not non-local right and that's a really
deep property right so you have to be
able to deal with non-local
relationships the most obvious example
is how do you deal with let's say and
pronouns and the thing that they refer
to the so called antecedents I say like
you know and Shawn was finished with his
recording and he asked me to give him
another glass of wine
what is the him yeah is that that could
be Shawn but that could be someone else
could be some other him could not be me
but how do you know that off the fly it
knows because there's actually a
structural relationship between the
pronoun or
and and the antecedent if you use
himself it can only refer so these are
kind of trivial examples but they
highlight a very special property namely
the property of M sort of what's
commonly called that there are
constituents or constituents are just
equivalence classes right so
constituents when I say you know course
screenings yeah the red can was on the
table then the red can is a constituent
it's a because I could say the
transparent glass was on so I can
substitute for something else and the
fact that you have such things and that
they are have of course causal force and
how we say stuff suggests that they make
you know there must be in your head
somehow or and unless you do a list and
that's fine to none but we don't be
doing this here I am NOT well I'm not
okay with that it doesn't work for me
some of my best friends are dual is I
mean if you have a brain with eighty
five billion neurons in it and as you
said each neuron has thousands of
friends right so lots of connections
it's a gigantic computational problem as
you said even if a most functional level
forgetting about meaning and abstraction
and poetry and music
we're in charge of this they just be
throwing gigantic computer power at it
and treating as a big data problem and I
do get the impression this is happening
also in neuroscience mm-hmm no that's
that's absolutely right I mean I think
that there were you know many of us
maybe all of us are seduced by the power
of by the computational power now
available right everybody and their
brother has you know some wicked GPU and
their laptop and the and but it is
changing ways in interesting ways maybe
it's good maybe it's bad the fact of the
matter is that the the data sizes that
we now collect the data amounts are
extremely large that's true so when I
stick someone in so like I put you in a
magneto encephalography scanner right so
we record it for let's say 10 minutes
that's about 2 gigabytes of data and
that's a lot of data and it's very and
so obviously you need to automatize the
analysis need to figure something out
the but now comes a very important
epistemological choice that you have to
make do you approach these data with
let's let's call it well it's almost
old-school with that hypothesis do you
actually have an idea were you looking
for something I mean is did you design
what you did with a particular thing in
mind so do you have a hypothesis a model
a theory um which is a very baked onion
and boring and you know but has done
pretty well last few hundred years I'm
not gonna lie yeah or do you and throw
do you pursue a kind of data-driven or
you know big data approach right the
thing and that's very popular because we
can write we have machines that do well
and you can certain problems are um
let's say at least descriptively
reasonably will address by simply
classifying things and here if you have
a classification problem then big data
is a cool approach you just throw you
know you train your network on
gazillions of trials and then you throw
some new data on it and maybe you have
even an unsupervised learning a
situation and you get a beautiful
clusters of things out them and I think
that's very powerful and I'm not gonna
lie we use that in my lab
and looking for literally 8:04 land you
basically look so let's be clear I mean
if you if you take this approach you're
looking at an orgy of data that's almost
treated hypothesis free it's purely
correlational approach you use for
address so it's basically the mother of
all regressions right and that's so what
might happen so in one universe you
might get lucky it might turn out that
the group that the regression you build
the giant correlation matrix which is
you know obscenely large turns out to
give you an interesting fractionation or
you know factorization of the problem
but what are the chances I mean I mean
it could happen but I mean there's a lot
of a no data are weird and messy and
noisy a lot of weird things could happen
and some I tell you my as I'm not
against this at all I mean we're
nobody's against having more data I mean
I kind of silly but the question is how
do you approach this data you've
collected and I mean I guess I'm very
sympathetic and you know in my own lab
we have vitriolic energetic debate I
love everybody in my lab wonderful
people but we don't all agree and and I
have you know lab members that are
strongly pushing me on this and I and
I'm strongly pushing back and I am I
believe it's a really good idea to
design the experiment with a question in
mind is if I stick you in a machine and
I'm gonna spend a lot of money energy
and time on recording these really quite
sophisticated complicated data I kind of
want to know what I'm looking for and
look I mean a very very big version of
this is the Large Hadron Collider you
don't build that thing you know just
because it let's just correlate a bunch
of stuff oh no but exactly the same
debate is going on between targeted
searches and sort of blank surface for
some some anomaly in something somewhere
ya know you might interpret it I I'm
sympathetic to finding things by
serendipity but my own feeling is still
that are from you know my own hunches
that actually a very well articulated
model that can then be shown to be wrong
reduces the nature of the problem and
I'm simply not satisfied by some giant
correlation matrix or or you know the
answer there are regression those are
engineering solutions in my own you know
as I noted before my sort of gut feeling
is that in the neurosciences
in the summer of 2018 engineering
approaches and Big Data approaches are
actually replacing the standard approach
of the sciences hmm I mean and that's a
little weird that engineering is
superseding science but is it a
temporary if enthusiasm that well it's
where we're all enthusiastic cuz it's
cool to be able to look at gigantic
amounts of things but here's the danger
the danger is that we end up maybe it's
not a danger maybe I'm just an old guy
maybe an old angry guy and I I think the
potential danger is that we become
theoretically myopic there is to say the
kinds of answers that are yielded by
this approach are of a certain form and
we will only be getting that form of
answer at the a form of answer that
comes out of giant regressions right and
that may be theoretically misleading
that is we might have a generation of
science in which the answers that are
provided us come from that from that
kind of epistemological stance and
prevent us from seeing theoretical
alternatives that are not you know fully
aligned with that approach which i think
would be a huge bummer so ironically by
not having a theoretical framework with
which to analyze and construct the
experiment you're locking yourself into
certain possible things you could
discover that's right and refusing to
look for other ones I'm in my own so I'm
working on this problem with one of my
colleagues right now so the way we're
trying to I mean so our diagnosis of
this is we're not at all against using
huge amounts of data it's exciting but
here's our diagnosis suppose you run a
big data approach on a neuroscience
problem so let's say you know I want to
study you know spoken word recognition
something I actually know something a
little bit about rent and what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna record I'm just gonna
have you know a thousand people listen
to ten thousand words some giant date I
mean I'm gonna crank this thing through
my you know convolutional neural network
and then I'm gonna get some interesting
classification scheme out of it and I
can probably record in different layers
and you're looking at what happens in
the brain when they're listening to
these words so to look for correlation
and I'm just gonna record this and I'm
just going to take this data and I'm
going to correlate everything with
everything right so and of course some
correlations will come out that's great
now let's say I end up with a very good
model but a terrific model fits and that
model will be characterized by a series
of parameters and it's gonna be great
and let's say it has you know 14
different things that I had to tweak
awesome now I have a fantastic model and
I have these 14 these 14 values I've got
a Kappa because you got to have a Kappa
okay maybe a towel yes good lambda
lambda nice let's go to a couple of lamb
does it go okay so now I have these
parameters that are fixed and they yield
the optimal thing what do I have to
what's my next step
my next step presumably is to do quote
unquote normal science on what these
parameters are right so I now have just
bit myself in the butt I have to say
well I have these fourteen things now I
have to actually figure out what they
are because they are the ones that are
ostensibly the causal that they have the
force of being explanatory for the model
so what gives I mean I think that's fine
but that my so my you know we our
argument is that the this is a lovely
approach but in the end you're gonna
actually reinvent what you have to do to
begin with to give a full comprehensive
explanatory account of the parameters of
your machine learned models so you think
that there's still room for human
thought and language in trying to
understand human thought and language I
think you need human thought you need
just common sense yeah solid common
sense no [ __ ] have a good [ __ ]
detector uh-huh and read all the details
and and and don't worry about and it's
and it turns out you have to actually do
though you have to do the homework yeah
good device we'd like to leave on a good
advice so I can't do better than do the
homework so David well thank you very
much for be on the bus thank you
[Music]